hey guys Pete peppers here and we're
going to talk about this is a long
overdue video I really didn't make one
about this because the specials worked
the same and jelly as they do in soda
but since this is you know jelly has
become so popular that I figure there's
enough players who might not know when
they start out playing it so we're gonna
talk about specials and combos and right
there I just made a striped candy that
happens when you mix four candies
together alright so like right above
where I just made the wrapped you can
see that there I can move that orange
one down and I make a stripe thing to
notice about stripes is whatever
direction you move the candy is whatever
the stripes go they're either horizontal
or vertical and that's one of the first
combos and it's it's an oldie but a
goodie the stripe plus the wrapped is
takes out three rows at a time instead
of just the single row which is what the
striped candy does so there's another
striped and the wrap does you make that
with the L shape or a t-shaped wrapped
candy blows up there's a fish also you
do that by making a square of for the
wrapped candy will blow up a three by
three square striped candy will hit a
row like I said either vertical or
horizontal depending and the fish will
swim off and it'll it'll hit one of the
one of the other big like it can hit a
you know a lot of different things there
you can see how we got the three by
three square cleared out by using the
wrapped I have a fish video that goes
into more detail about what they do on
the different kinds of boards and guide
so I'll put a link to that in this video
here and this is just something you know
whenever you make a special match with
the special it fires it off and leave
them behind so I made a square with four
yellows one of them was a fish so the
fish got fired off and there was a
left behind
we try to set up a few more things and
then I have I'll do it I'll do a well
I'm just playing around a little bit now
you can make a striped here you can
match that with the fish and the fish
will swim off and hit one of the squares
and it takes on the properties of both
another fish red square if we match
these two stripes together then it'll go
vertical and horizontal at the same time
if we moved it down it would it would go
across the bottom if we move it up it'll
hit that licorice coil and set off the
fish to its left and you see that the
fish went off and it hit one of the
coils because that's one of the blockers
on this board to fish together sends off
three C three swim away and hit coils
for us
make a stripe this is set off this
stripe then you'll have one left behind
so you know the the the the basics
here's another wrap to see how that's an
L shape if I move that together it would
become a wrap and it will also set off
that right so there are some you know
like I said I've written about this and
have other videos about this for and so
to you know the basic specials
definitely changed but they are the same
they're a little bit different in the
original saga but they're the same and
soda and jelly color bombs do different
things they're you know they're
basically the same but they do a little
bit different things in combos wraps do
a little bit different in combos the
striped plus wrap is still the same as
it is in the original but the thing with
specials especially in you know spread
the jam levels and you know levels with
a lot of blockers and things you know
the a lot of times you're not going to
be able to finish unless you don't get
together some combos they can do so much
more so much faster so you really need
to learn what happens when you mix them
together and like I said we'll get into
that bomb combos are the best but like I
said even the very simple original
strike plus raft is still a pretty good
one here we can make a color bomb it's
it isn't when you match five together
you can see we have two at the top two
at the bottom of orange and we move this
other orange over wearing a color bomb
if you set a color bomb off by itself
what happens is you get it'll take off
that entire color that's where the name
color bomb comes from and here we're
gonna make ourselves a coloring candy
and what's different here is that you
make it in the same way except there's
one extra of that color connected so you
know it could be six it could be seven
could even be eight but there's our
coloring candy and this was new and soda
but in jelly it's the same so I'm gonna
match this is we're gonna show the first
combo here
I talked about some of the differences
between the color bomb and the color and
candy coloring candy if you use it by
itself it'll just change one color but
if we make if we make it into a combo
it's kind of like twice as strong
because unlike the color bomb which
doesn't have a color a coloring candy
does so if we match this yellow coloring
candy with this red fish all the red
candies will turn into fish but also all
the yellows will and one thing you might
not notice in the beginning when you
first start using them is is that like
say if I use the coloring bomb hit the
red it would turn all the red of the
fish and they would all go off on by one
but watch here see how there's like two
waves that come together when you use
coloring candy it's sort of like the
yellow ones fire off and then the red
ones fire off they can actually hit more
blockers and things because of that like
they could hit the same one over and
over like if you know if you were
playing you know and soda for example if
you were playing a honey level you know
they're gonna go where the Bears are so
you could actually get two hits on each
bear with the coloring candy fish
instead of just one with the the color
bomb fish
so whenever you whenever you're playing
different levels different level types
you know you just kind of want to think
about what's the combos do and then what
would be the best one for that
particular situation color bombs or
common candies puffs wraps are great to
clear out huge bases across the board
striped plus the color bomb it's sort of
the same thing it's going to just send
off a bunch of striped candies
everywhere if you have it with the
coloring candy here we'll go ahead I
think and make this like this color bomb
and you see every red candy on the board
turns into a color bomb and you see
that's extra helpful and the deli one
because it actually spreads the jelly as
its as it goes around so you know they
would have never been able to cover that
much of it and just one one shot before
so they here are some different ones
this is a color bomb impulsive striped
so yeah all the red I matched it with
red so all the red candies turned into a
striped candy spread out all across the
board this is another example of the
color bomb plus the wrapped it's gonna
fire turn them all into color bombs and
see how they drop down they blow up they
blow up twice so that's obviously your a
lot of a lot of clearing power with that
here's a fish plus the collarbone and
look how it's a little bit different
because there's no color so just the red
ones will turn into fish and they all
sort of go off and go just that you know
one particular square apiece
here's a color bomb plus a color bomb
this is a this has a different effect in
regular candy crush it would come out
and it would sort of clear things off
one by one and here we get a big
explosion it kind of clears the board
watch our coils all disappear and every
piece on the board gets cleared out so
if you had blockers it would take one
layer off of every blocker on the board
and you see on the jelly the area it
didn't spread it if we had jelly up in
the top like above where the explosion
was then it sort of would have spread it
in that direction like towards the
corner like that we'll try to get some
let's go through some coloring candy
combos now so a coloring candy by itself
it'll change a color it's not always
really effective to use but not as a
combo but a candy in some situations so
here we can match a orange with the
green that would turn all the green
orange or we can match green with a
green and what that does is it takes out
the color that is sort of the most
effective no watch will change them all
back all the green ones back to orange
when we match the only phone with it so
that's the basic the basic thing you can
see there that worked pretty good to
clear out the bottom of the board just
because we had a lot of stuff matching
and cascading and things but it gets a
lot better sort of like when we saw it
with the fish earlier it gets a lot
better when you use in a combo one of
the things when you're making specials
and combos that you want to think about
is one of the mistakes I'm I can make
time from time to time it's trying to
hold on to them too long and set up a
combo because you know you always want
to check and think about how many moves
you have before you decide how you're
going to use them because if you don't
use them in a timely fashion then you're
gonna end up just running out of moves
before you get the the effect so you
don't want to take take some time and
and
way the thing you know way your choices
so here's this in another example we can
make a special with the special and you
know it fired it off changed one color
over and we still have our color bomb
left behind here's another example with
the striped and the coloring candy this
this will if this was like yellow then
it would turn all the yellow and green
but since it's green and green it's
gonna change the green plus one other
color and you see that we did strike
throw every place you see how how much
of the board that cleared out just like
that so that's always it's always a good
thing to get here is the coloring candy
crush the collarbone some people would
say this is the best that I think it's
it's up there as one of the best combos
it is slightly different than two color
bombs it does the same thing you get
Jenny flying across so it it clears anak
has a big explosion clears the board but
it actually takes two layers off of two
layers off of blockers so it's twice as
powerful clears things out twice as fast
I think I'll put another color bomb plus
color won't yeah right here look at the
look at the ice here the ice is some of
it has two layers some of it has one
when I when I explode this it'll take
one layer off so you'll see that all the
stuff that was double hmm had one left
behind if we had added had been a color
and candy plus a color bomb it would
have cleared the whole board and we
would have finished the level right
there
so here's one we missed earlier it's a
rap plus a wrapped and like I mentioned
a regular collar a regular match candy a
wrapped candy clears out a 3x3 square
when we match two wraps together it
clears out a 5 by 5 square so it'll even
you know hit the stuff that to past
those holes over there which the regular
one wouldn't have and you also set up
the coloring candies that we're near by
divine and here is the coloring candy +
the Colin cane it's sort of the most
elusive it doesn't matter which two
colors you have what it does is it turns
all the candy pieces on the board the
same color which I'll you know which you
know will often make a bunch of other
cool combos as it matches together do
that so you have a big cascade that's
all filled with specials and it clears
out a ton of the board and depending on
you know what you're doing it could be
the most effective one you just have to
figure it out based on like what else is
happening on the board or whatever so
and like I said I'll put some links in
this video up and you know with cards
where you can watch some of the you know
the original video I made about the soda
the soda ones and link you to where my
guides are and how I have a table what
all the combos produce and I also have
for the newer ones I have you know like
the guide that explains how to use it
which I guess would be a good read
especially if you're new but even if
you've been playing for a while there
might be some things in there that you
hadn't realized in the past so
hope this gives you a pretty
comprehensive look at what is what and
for specials by now I'm guessing that
you realize how important they can be so
try to make them when you can try to
plan out like what what's gonna be the
best for your level I hope this was
helpful
and if you have any questions I'll try
to answer them in the comments make sure
you like it and subscribe to our video
so that more people will find this
content and let me know what other
videos you'd like to see in the future I
like to make how to play I kind of left
this this one out just because of the
fact like I said that the soda stuff was
the same but I'm getting ready to add
some new guides and things some how to
play guides for jelly saga on my website
candy crush soda saga tips calm so I
wanted to make this video to place it
there so I'll talk to you soon thanks
for watching the video thanks for the
subscription and the likes have a good
one